yeah but the pay Gap like like no two  groups are going to be paid the same but  they should be that's why this country  you've you've seen there's there's  certain countries that actually do have  this openness about what people's  salaries are right and when salaries are  not disclosed that's when you see a pay  a gap well I'm saying like 60 of women  have never asked for a raise so how can  so how about but I'm saying how can we  complain about something when like we're  not asking for races why are you not  asking that's a real question because  we're yeah we're [ __ ] we're scared  hopefully you're worth it well what do  you mean do you don't believe you're  worth what women well women no I'm  saying I'm saying I'm saying no I'm  saying I'm saying women are more  agreeable so we're more likely to agree  we're men so but I'm saying that's  biology that's not the society